[Music]
welcome back to this Hannity special
twenty20 election at this week's
Democrat presidential debates radical
Democrats unleashed on the hot-button
issue of abortion watch this it's also
not forget someone in the trans
community a trans female this poor
doesn't mean they shouldn't have the
right to exercise that right to choose
and so I absolutely would cover the
right to have an abortion I would make
certain that every woman has access to
the full range of reproductive health
care services and that includes birth
control it includes abortion it includes
everything for a woman first of all let
me tell you this didn't you come up here
but let's face this Medicare for all
guarantees every woman in this country
the right to have an abortion if she
wants it meanwhile Hollywood liberals
continue to prop up Democratic Party
policies and on Fox and Friends
legendary actor Jon Voight responded to
a Twitter attack from radical actress
Alyssa Milano who's been leading the
call for Hollywood to boycott the state
of Georgia over its fetal heartbeat
abortion law watch this darling Alyssa
but you know I pray God sends his light
of truth on all those with no truth
about the Republicans and about our
president you know I may god bless
america
joining us now with reaction is Trump
2020 campaign national press secretary
Kaley mcenany and Daily Caller reporter
Carrie Pinkett Kaley I'll go to you
first Alyssa Milano criticizing Jon
Voight that's kind of a joke in and of
itself I mean she was in
what is it Beverly Hills Chihuahua - and
he won an Academy Award
I thought he handled it quite well but I
guess my question to you is more this
Hollywood really matter anymore clearly
it didn't help Hillary in the 2016
election no Hollywood doesn't matter in
fact I think if anything it's a curse
for a candidate because everyday
hard-working men and women look and they
say Alyssa Milano is going to tell me
what to do I mean this is the woman who
said that women should have a sector
because of a fetal heartbeat bill that
says you keep a living baby with a
heartbeat alive and because of that bill
women everywhere should have a sex
strike I can tell you this women
everywhere every day women listen to her
tune her out she doesn't matter nor does
Hollywood they are a joke so please
endorse the Democratic nominee as I'm
sure they will you know Carrie I brought
this up multiple times on the show
tonight what focus group is given the
Democrats the absolutely awful advice
that abortion up to the ninth month of
pregnancy is a winner outside of maybe
certain enclaves in New York California
and in Illinois it's absurd I mean what
happened is safe legal and rare it seems
to have gone out the window so true dim
and think about this right after Ralph
Northam governor of Virginia made his
absurd comments that about about post
birth abortions Democrats began to get a
little scared they didn't want to talk
about it and they explicitly steered
away from it during the debates however
and it doesn't mean that a little crazy
didn't come out specifically out of
hooli and Castro about the trans
community being able to have abortions I
think they're calling it now
reproductive justice but still they they
now want to repeal the Hyde Amendment
which means that federal taxpayer
dollars would actually go towards
abortions they want to make sure that
they vilify all these states that ended
up passing these heartbeat bills so
still you have a number of Democrats who
want to make sure that they don't make
the same mistake that Hillary Clinton
made back in 2016 when she said that she
would support abortion all the way up
through the third trimester Kaley this
cannot play well in swing states here
meme you look at one issue voters people
who vote on one issue you see basically
firearms Second Amendment and abortion
this is not gonna look good for the
Democrats once these primaries are over
this radicalism on abortion oh you're
right you know this motivates the
Republican base immensely but more than
that it motivates eighty five percent of
Americans when you look at who supports
abortion until birth which was passed in
New York and celebrated with a sick
standing ovation in the New York Senate
chamber and they lit one world trade
pink in celebration when you look at who
supports this absurd and humane measure
of killing a fully viable baby it is
about
tene course percent or less so they are
motivating 85% the American people when
they do things like nineteen times
blocking a vote in the house for a
keepalive bill keeping a baby alive
outside of the womb purportedly those
Democrats agree with the governor of
Virginia that you can now commit
infanticide this is sick and they are
quickly becoming the party of the 1% the
1% who support infanticide Kerry I just
got a few seconds left but it's one
thing to argue for choice is not really
choice we see you know it's not a choice
for the infant in the womb it's a whole
other thing to argue for unlimited
abortion I mean can they possibly turn
back after the primary and turn back in
the general on this no way Dan just
think about it the whole idea of arguing
third trimester abortions on a national
stage the details of going into that I
don't see it and frankly I only see the
Democrats going away from it I agree
thanks for really appreciate it you both
are great